if you want to hear
some great elvis music and one of the
best performances
from any actor portraying elvis you need
to watch this movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're going into this looking for a
very deep biopic something that of the
likes of james mangled or though we saw
from brian singer on bohemian rhapsody
or even uh oliver stone when he did the
doors about jim morrison
you may be wanting a bit more out of
this film what's up guys i'm bobby and i
am back talking about elvis the 2022
biopic directed by baslerman starring
austin butler as the king of rock and
roll elvis bresli and tom hanks as
colonel tom parker and uh yeah this film
runs about two and a half hours
thereabouts i mean there's already been
some reviews out there online but i
needed to talk about this feel man i i'm
i grew up in las vegas
uh
elvis was a big part of my life growing
up my mom was a huge elvis fan of course
living in vegas
elvis i mean the dna of elvis is all
over the place people get married by
elvis over in vegas right so
you know and i watched his movies
growing up as a kid i was just i was a
big fan personally and so i was super
pumped to see this film you know i i
really wanted to see a deep biopic of
elvis but of course you want to see the
songs you want to see the performances
you want to see an actor encapsulate
elvis in that very magical way that
makes him the king of rock and roll
which he's an icon you know he's like i
mean
it's elvis right and so i was super
excited for this film and when i saw the
trailers come out i'm like wow baslerman
has knocked it out of the park visually
just looks awesome and it does this film
is one of the most beautiful films of
2022 thus far i think in terms of
cinematography right now the battles of
2022 is between top gun 2 and elvis
each our own distinctive in their own
way but both are amazing when it comes
to cinematography and this film is
absolutely stunning so i come into the
theater i'm sitting there and i'm ready
to just be enveloped
by elvis in a way i've never seen him on
screen
and i'll tell you what
um
there are a lot of great things of this
movie as i said visually it's beautiful
austin butler
has portrayed elvis in a way we've never
seen in cinema he doesn't look exactly
like elvis but i will tell you within
the first 10 minutes or so
you are gonna you see elvis on screen
the way he speaks the way he sings
because he's actually doing a lot of his
own singing in this the way he moves
this actor this is his star performance
this is like
how east of eden was james dean's
breakout role
this is austin butler's breakout rule
this is his east of eden i mean this is
wow what a what a performance man what a
performance if he doesn't get nominated
i am just going to be shocked because
he's the king
he is the king and you go through this
film going oh my god
it's scary it's uncanny it's like he's
channeling something which is awesome to
see all right before i continue
here's a message from our sponsor blog
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if pew leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
uh tom hanks is colonel tom parker um
it's like he's playing a caricature of
this guy it's a little bit odd and i
know there's been some talk about his
performance in it but yeah he's a little
bit over the top at times the accent the
some of the performance and i love tom
hanks he's one of the best actors of our
generation but i felt like he could have
dialed it down a bit but i think maybe
this was part of baslerman's you know
how he saw the film as being a little
bit uh larger than life and creating
this larger than life persona but anyway
getting back to it i sat down and i got
into this and you know this movie moves
at a blistering pace it just goes right
off the bat you don't even see you get
you know flashbacks of elvis as a kid
you kind of get this sort of this comic
book they use as montage comic book
style because he was a big fan of
superheroes uh describe how elvis grew
up he grew up in this black neighborhood
and with his mom and everything else his
dad went to jail and he grew up kind of
a hard you know had some hardships in
his life but that was his influence of
course with black music and uh the
african-americans that he was living
around and all that stuff so that was a
big part of him and of course he's from
memphis tennessee which is the south so
bam i mean this is his dna but you go
right into elvis from his first big hit
you go right into him becoming a star
and you go right along the way and i
feel
that there was so much about elvis in
the early years that a lot of us don't
know
and it would have been great to actually
dive deeper into that to find out how
elvis kind of created this persona for
himself it wasn't just tom parker that
was doing this
or sam phillips it was from sun records
it was also elvis like what was in his
mind how did he create this persona you
know and and make it such a a thing and
and i'll tell you it we didn't really
get into that that much i mean it's
beautiful the performances are great the
music's fantastic but it just kind of
goes hyperspace all the way through his
early days
and
you miss out on some integral moments
that i as a fan of elvis i wanted to see
on film i wanted that to see those
moments portrayed
and you know you you tap on certain
moments as he goes into you know he gets
into the you know get drafted into the
military because he had to do it of
course because
you know obviously the problems that he
was having because he was moving and
dancing in a way that people thought it
was obscene and so to sort of soften the
blow colonel tom parker said look he
worked out a deal with the government he
enlists he becomes this all-american boy
we kind of see a little bit of that but
then it passes right on through it boom
you meet priscilla bam you're going into
hollywood it's just like whoa buzz
slow down man
this is the king of rock and roll we
don't want to just see a
a two and a half hour movie of music
which is great and it's fantastic and he
does a great job singing and dancing and
performing these
these numbers but we want to see elvis
and so many integral parts of his story
like the age gap between him and
priscilla was never discussed ever so
many other point moments i mean they
talk about the beatles hover beetles
were the you know the next big thing but
they never they never got into they
tapped a little bit into but they never
got really into the beatles and elvis
and how that relationship i mean from
what i understand they kind of you know
had a little jam session together but
they did know each other and what was
that like and
and just all these different facets of
his history when they go right into
vegas right after that and his tour
there and they do die they
baslerman does slow down a little bit
when we get into vegas a bit more to
sort of tap into that but it's really
about
he sees this elvis story through the
eyes of tom parker played by tom hanks
for the most part and it's sort of like
how tom parker perceived elvis
versus how elvis perceived himself or
how other people saw it and i felt like
that was a big missed opportunity and
while the film is absolutely beautiful
austin butler should be getting he
should be nominated for an academy award
out of this or at least the golden globe
award because he was just he's just
fantastic in this um tom hanks
also really good but as i said a little
bit over the top with his caricature of
tom parker at times
you just miss on that essence that
emotional chord so the movie's two and a
half hours and at times it feels very
long and i was talking with some friends
at abby from geek culture as a matter of
fact we were watching it together
and she's doing the written review on
this and she's like a movie feels really
long and i said you know why it's
because you don't have that emotional
attachment to elvis and this the way you
should have this attachment like how
james mangle did with walk the line with
joaquin phoenix you know or how we saw
with bohemian rhapsody with uh you know
freddie mercury directed by brian singer
like or even like the doors by oliver
stone how you get into the mind of jim
morrison we never got that emotional
attachment here with elvis and i felt
that was a missed opportunity that baz
was so into the aesthetics and so into
the music which is beautiful
but you miss those opportunities i mean
as a matter of fact to give you an
example
priscilla presley his wife right i mean
you know icon
she maybe has two or three dialogue
scenes in this entire film everything
else she's sort of just like a shoulder
piece
and i'm like
okay
i mean i guess we're seeing elvis
through the eyes of tom parker here
but
what do we want to know about the more
about their marriage about the
relationship about you know the trials
and tribulations i mean we get a little
bit of that of course you know obviously
because they get separated and
you know she can't deal with the drugs
and the alcohol and all that kind of
stuff but you know i mean
what is it
what is it with elvis what is put what
is what is doing this and
and i think that we're missing those
kind of things and i think that's the
that's the unfortunate part of this
movie it is so beautiful
i love how baslerman crafted the story
in a lot of ways but he just sped
through so many poignant moments of
elvis's life that by the end of it
you're like
it kind of feels like a two and a half
hour music montage of the best hits of
elvis like you don't even get jailhouse
rock for that matter you don't even get
that iconic setting you know with the
stage in the background and the white
and black you don't even get that in the
movie you don't even get jailhouse rock
the hell anyway
sorry i mean look to be frank with you
to do a movie like this it would have to
be three hours or longer right but you
know what
i wouldn't mind watching that kind of
movie we've already seen long movies
already for the past you know over the
past six months with batman and
spider-man and all these things
but elvis deserves that elvis needs that
and told the right way the audience
would be crying at the end of this movie
they would their heart would break for
this man
who
lost himself
and at the end of it you just go
okay
and that's not what i wanted to feel
from this movie so do i recommend you
seeing it yes the music you elvis fans
are gonna absolutely love it austin
butler is phenomenal as i mentioned
repeatedly in this video
tom hanks is okay in this
but if you're looking for that emotional
core that that
that gravitas
as an elvis fan if you're in the you
know older generation and you're wanting
that you're gonna miss out but for the
new generation that wants to learn about
the king of rock and roll
you know what
welcome to elvis anyway those are my
thoughts on the movie let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
like always follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube like this
video helps us out a lot take care stay
safe and i'll chat to you soon
[Music]
elvis the man was sacrificed